the one thing that we always think about
we think oh China's through the engine
of global growth and so therefore the
world is reliant on it that's not true
China is not an engine of global growth
yes they've got a lot of growth but
they're not the engine because to be an
engine of global growth a country has
got to buy the goods and services of
other countries to create growth
elsewhere and what China has done
through predatory trade policies and
through the theft of intellectual
property has taken growth from other
countries
so yes countries have relations with
with China Australia for instance sells
them a lot of iron ore but that iron ore
is put into products that end up Beano
in the shelves of Europe and the United
States so I think that essentially
Australia will be selling to India or
Vietnam or someplace else for sales to
the US these global supply chains if
they are forced will readjust and
they're already doing that anyway for a
number of reasons
you know si Jinping has been pushing
companies out of China also president
Trump's so-called trade war has been
pulling companies out of China I think
that that process will accelerate
because of the chronic virus epidemic we
are going to reduce our reliance on
China as a producer of pharmaceuticals
and obviously medical protective
equipment so these things are going to
happen anyway but I think that they're
certainly going to be accelerated and
they should be accelerated I don't think
they're the engine obviously I know u.s.
is 100% the engine there's no question
about that I'm 100% capitalist I we
escaped Iran to go to Germany refugee
camp to come here because this is the
American dream nobody wakes up and says
the Chinese dream they say the American
dream it's only one kind of a dream but
1.6 billion is a lot of people you know
when you can produce things for nothing
by a communist that government ran on a
you know wink-wink capitalistic economy
controlled by national I mean so it
concerns me to know 17% and it concerns
me to know how many countries are
relying on them
[Music]